et cette mort troublante il faut bien le
dire de yefghani pregojin on va
l'évoquer tout de suite avec notre
chroniqueuse internationale avec nous en
plateau Armelle Charlier bonjour Armel
Armel la question que tout le monde se
pose depuis l'annonce de ce crash et
donc de cette mort de yefghani privé
est responsable de cette mort
la réponse prendra du temps à être
fourni parce que comme l'indique
d'ailleurs le président russe il y a une
enquête évidemment en Russie et compte
tenu du fait de la complexité de ce
territoire on est aujourd'hui
principalement sur des spéculations ce
qui est intéressant c'est que les
Américains ont un peu analysé la ligne
en fait avec laquelle l'avion avait
plongé ils sont donc déduits que l'avion
n'avait pas pu avoir un accident que
forcément il y avait eu un coup un
impact et que du coup c'était ça qu'il
avait fait tomber ça se le renseignement
américain qui se pose d'un certain
nombre d'informations ensuite tout
laisse à penser évidemment au fait que
il y a eu un règlement de compte parce
que c'est aussi une des grandes
traditions de la Russie de régler des
comptes avec les opposants ou les
personnes qui se mettent sur le terrain
ce qui est intéressant dans les propos
aujourd'hui de Vladimir Poutine c'est
qu'il prend la parole de façon publique
en tant que Président il s'adresse aussi
à son opinion nationale aussi il y a des
gens qui performances sont en train de
pleurer aussi on a vu des images de gens
qui regrettaient la mort du chef de
Wagner et que donc du coup il met la
subtilité qu'il faut mettre lorsque vous
avez quelqu'un comme ça qui vous a
accompagné pendant autant d'années qui a
été l'homme grill l'homme de l'ombre qui
a fait vos œuvres vos basses mais les
meilleurs aussi et avec lesquels
derrière vous êtes rentré dans une
opposition en frontale puisque lorsque
vous avez une tentative de coup d'état
même si elle ne le visait pas
directement et qu'ensuite précoce elle
disait l'armée russe évidemment se
caresse quand même une tentative de
prendre le pouvoir sur Vladimir Poutine